bonjour marie-hélène utah bonjour
bertrac argouges et bonjour aux
auditeurs de la première radio
conseillère exécutive en charge du
patrimoine et de la culture
1848 2018 nous sommes cent soixante dix
ans après la fin du régime esclavagiste
pour la martinique et plus largement de
la pratique de l'esclavagé en france et
nous voilà maintenant nous martinique
est en train d'expérimenter une
collectivité territoriale dans une sorte
de décentralisation très poussée on va
dire pour aller vite et avec un niveau
de vie tout de même au niveau de vie
économique que bien des pays voisins
pourraient nous envier
que faut-il en penser selon vous
marie-hélène et août 1 de cette
situation je crois que le peuplement
tonique et il est en train de continuer
petit à petit son cheminement vers eux
plus d'émancipation plus de
responsabilités c'est ainsi qu'on peut
traduire ce passage il y a deux ans et
demi à la collectivité unique la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
c'est nous sommes en train
d'expérimenter on peut dire toujours
mais je crois que nous avons fait un pas
vers plus de responsabilités c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir sous un petit
territoire quand même 11 cents
kilomètres carrés mais tenez aux deux
collectivités deux assemblées deux
exécutifs sous le même territoire avec
le même périmètre
ce qui n'est pas le cas de la france je
pense que il fallait faire ce pas pour
passer à la collectivité unique
mais alors vous avez eu l'occasion de
dire lors d'un discours
1,22 même semble qu'il ya trois ou
quatre ans une santé en 2014
c'est assez simple mais à la fois assez
vide en saisir le sens des
commémorations du 22 mai s'est posé les
jalons pour renforcer notre cohésion et
notre détermination
oui tout à fait ça et c'est ce que l'on
constate année après année le 22 mai en
soi n'est pas un problème pour les
martiniquais
la question qu'il faut se poser
aujourd'hui c'est après 22 mai qui ça
nos cafés
côté local et qu'ils y sont nous
captiver de toutes ses veines matin là
parce que la date en soit j'ai dit ne
pose plus problème le problème qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est que à travers
cette date qui fait une unité chez les
martiniquais de tous les courants
politiques toutes les confessions
religieuses etc
il a qu'à voir le la marge la retraite
aux flambeaux qui a été fait par
l'église dernièrement à partir de là
qu'est ce que nous faisons pour
renforcer notre unité sur les problèmes
d'aujourd'hui
bien entendu les problèmes d'aujourd'hui
on les connaît le chlordécone les
sargasses le chu de martinique
et puis d'autres ce sont des problèmes
qui doivent rassembler les martiniquais
qui soit capable puisqu'ils sont en
termes de responsabilité qui sont
capables de proposer des solutions
elle existe des solutions marion donc
faisons cette cohésion pour apporter des
solutions parce que il y à de graves
problèmes de santé publique juste une
grosse cohésion et détermination et par
rapport au trois difficultés trois
domaines là qui sont qui nous occasionne
des crises un finalement santé publique
notamment
on se rend compte que cent soixante dix
ans après 1848 la société martiniquaise
les martiniquaises des martiniquais ont
une forte tendance certains diraient
même un réflexe à tort ou à raison en
tout cas de se tourner vers l'état pour
tenter de régler ses difficultés
justement mais c'est vrai nom il faut
bien comprendre nous sommes pas payés
débandade
nous avons un état nous nous sommes dans
cet état même s'il est à 7000 km en fait
même si le siège jeu et à 7000 km mais
nous faisons partie de cet état la
france a décidé et c'est elle qui l'a
décidé elle a décidé de nos cadres de
nous garder dans son ensemble mo je vais
pas employer un terme jeudi dans
l'ensemble français
la france a décidé et nous aussi nous
étions d'accord en 1946 à vous cette loi
de départementalisation est ensuite
dernièrement en 2015 la mise en place de
la collectivité unique
c'est nous qui l'avons demandé c'est
nous qui l'avons voté il ya eu un
référendum et enfin de consultation
populaire
donc nous sommes dans cette somme c'est
tout le monde qui doit prendre en charge
ce problème ce sont les collectivités
locales
bien sûr les communes en premier lieu
puisque c'est sous le territoire de
telle ou telle commune
c'est aussi la collectivité de
martinique
mais c'est aussi l'état comment
voulez-vous que d une portion voulait
aussi accord ou surtout surtout et avant
tout l'état
c'est ce que j'aime bien partir c'est ça
se pose pas en termes de suez où tout
avant tout vous avez un ensemble vous
avez des responsables tout le monde doit
prenez pour les marges
maintenant quand il faudra mettre
l'argent ya moyen vous trouver les fonds
ya les fonds de l'état est allé fois
euros payé également
donc on trouvera en mettra en place les
moyens financiers pour aborder le
problème parce qu'il ya des solutions
mais effectivement ça demande de
consomme d'argent et je crois que nous
n'avons pas encore pris conscience de
cela
alors marié l'année autant la place de
la culture et de la valorisation de nos
arts de nos patrimoines
qu'est-ce qu'elle quelle place elle elle
doit occuper quelle place elle doit
prendre
d'ailleurs at-elle
aujourd'hui encore justement
suffisamment sa place une place
importante dans notre entreprise
d'évolution de maturation sociétale oui
fidel castro le président fidel castro
disait de la période spéciale ou au cube
a été pratiquement isolée il avait perdu
le soutien de l'urss qui n'existait plus
que le président castro disait il faut
sauver la culture et ça veut dire
quelque chose de précis parce que la
culture c'est l'âme de peuples alors en
termes de politique culturelle
aujourd'hui et je ne cesserai de le
répéter
je veux que la culture soit un facteur
de développement favorisant l'avancée de
notre conscience historique d'où les
commémorations mais aussi ce très bel
âtre associés que nous avons présenté
hier soir à la venue des caraïbes
je veux que la culture également elles
permettent la consolidation de notre
conscience martiniquaise je parlais de
cohésion d'unités sur des problèmes qui
sont des problèmes fondamentaux qui
concerne tous les martiniquais
travailler pour la cohésion nationale
c'est cela et plus généralement la
culture est un facteur de développement
favorisant ce que j'appelle l'élévation
humaine c'est-à-dire l'envi d'aller vers
le beau vers le vrai le juste le biais
c'est ça et ça c'est tous les pays au
fait de diriger des voter c'est surtout
les pays ça sur les orientations
générales
maintenant il s'agit de ron de société
meilleurs mettre concrètement comment
allons-nous faire ça nous avons trois
projets jeudi emblématique que nous
avons commencé à mettre en route il ya
l'école des armes que quitter c'était
c'était dans notre programme
l'enseignement artistique
il nous offre une possibilité formidable
c'est de réussir une avancée dans les
processus d'éducation l'éducation
artistique est fondamentale le deuxième
projet emblématique
c'est ce musée d'art contemporain que
nous allons e m au palais de justice à
l'ancien place juste et ça donc au
centre ville et je reviens de la
biennale de dakar au centre camille
version wii c'est ce qu'on appelle
espace calme aussi
l'ancien palais de justice en janvier de
la biennale de dakar où est un ancien
palais de justice de le vieux d'accord
qui est désaffecté c'est là qu'ils ont
mis les oeuvres central de cette
biennale est le dernier projet qui est
des quilles et de boulons nous l'avons
créé nous avons responsable c'est
l'office de la langue crayola ça c'est
important aussi la langue ça fait partie
de la culture du peuple
et j'espère aussi que sous la première
les émissions en créole que vous faites
de radio en fait une formation que et
autres que l'on va mais tenir cela
également sur la première radio est
aussi télé alors le programme de ce cent
soixante dixième anniversaire de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé au niveau de
la collectivité territoriale
il apparaît il semble plutôt modeste ce
programme est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire ce qui est prévu alors il ya la
bibliothèque schoelcher c'est vrai
qu'ils commémorent à travers d'une série
de conférences des expositions etc
mais quand on va sur le site de la ctm
on ne voit que ce que ça le jeu alors il
reste plein 10 dollars à peine les
rendez-vous sont multiples en fait le 22
mai c'est un moment de commémoration
bien sûr c'est un moment de réflexion de
discussion c'est aussi un moment de joie
c'est d'ailleurs un aspect festif un
dock tous ses aspects les
applaudissements la partie moment de
commémoration nous avons plutôt laisser
ça aux partis politiques c'est vrai mais
moment de réflexion à hésiter la
bibliothèque schoelcher mais samedi soit
vous avez aussi l'écomusée de
rivière-pilote l'yonne en dévot toujours
samedi soir très important à la pagerie
il ya aussi un rendez-vous qui s'appelle
la pagerie ce quota avec les artistes de
l'île d'yeu pour le plaisir et à ce qui
passionne moment de réflexion aussi de
connaissances ya une brochure qui va
paraître la semaine prochaine qui
s'appelle la révolution anti
esclavagiste de mai 1948 en martinique à
et puis le moment de joie c'est le
rendez vous que nous donnons
l'après-midi du 22 mai après la torah à
la population
nous nous nous y reviendrons dans le
cette édition merci marie-hélène de
houtain bonne journée à vous tous merci